AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
BLOWING UP THE GRAMS.
LAST WEEKEND, HUNTINGTON
BEACHED HOSTED THE 9TH ANNUAL
CORGI BEACH DAY!
HUH! YOU GUYS WERE ALL THERE.
IT LAUNCHED 1,000 INSTAGRAMS.
IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE GATHERING
OF JUGGALOS, WHERE IT'S
PARTICIPANTS CAN'T HELP
DRAGGING THEIR BELLIES THROUGH
THE MUD.
BUT IT'S FUN!
OVER 500 CORGIS CAME TOGETHER TO
WADDLE ON THEIR STUMPY LITTLE
LIMBS AND HAVE THEIR SOULS
STOLEN BY IPHOEN CAMERCA FLASH
BULBS.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO NAME
SOME THINGS THAT ARE MORE
INSTAGRAMMABLE THAN 500 CORGIS
ON THE BEACH.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK AND BEGIN.
YES, ADAM.
>> 500 CORGIS IN THONGS ON THE
BEACH.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
KURT.
>> RIHANNA'S CORGI DOING COKE
COACHELLA.
>> CHRIS: YEAH. POINTS.
KURT.
>> TWO KITTENS PLAYING
MINECRAFT.
>> Chris: POINTS. MEGAN.
>> JUST LIKE SOME SIDE BOOB LIKE
NEXT TO AN OMELET, NEXT TO A
GREEN JUICE.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
KURT.
>> 300 BABIES DOING THE
MACARENA.
>> Chris: GOD DAMN YOU, KURT.
WHY DID YOU PUT THAT IMAGE IN MY
HEAD?
POINTS. MEGAN.
>> A SELFIE WITH SO MANY FILTERS
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE BEING
ABDUCTED BY ALIENS.
>> Chris: ADAM.
>> A SIDE BOOB THAT IS ACTUALLY
A CLOSEUP OF A REALLY SMOOTH
TESTICLE.
>> Chris: POINTS.